here are the latest calls between former
president obama and president trump
hello so you're not gonna back down on
this ridiculous claim that i wiretapped
you huh
nope if i back down it makes me look
weak but if you don't back down it makes
you look crazy
no it makes you look crazy how does it
make me look crazy
if you didn't do it why do you keep
arguing with me about it
because you're great great that's why
[Applause]
hey barack about german chancellor
angela merkel yeah chancellor what the
hell is that it's just an old european
term for
head of state i think it could be a show
about a gambler he rolls the dice
he plays his cards he takes a chance for
he
is the chancellor this falls unboxed
what do you think
every day you're in power is a global
nightmare
hello hey barack i'm really peeved at
that judge in hawaii who overturned my
travel ban well he felt like it violated
the spirit of our laws
i feel like calling him up and telling
him hawaii by though
it means hello and goodbye in hawaii
would you know if you were actually from
there
gotcha did you see
i met with german chancellor angela
merkel i did
i think it went very well he's a nice
guy donald that's offensive angela
merkel is a woman
you